now to Ukraine where the government says
36 Russian missiles and drones aimed at
the capital were shot down overnight
Deborah patta visited a unit of
Ukrainian troops that have fought in
some of the toughest battles of the war
now they're training for a new
assignment she's in the eastern city of
Park Eve Deborah good morning
well good morning while Ukraine's a
debate system is holding strong
residents in the capital had a sleepless
night last night as Moscow stepped up
the intensity of their attacks
night after night Kiev is in the firing
line with Thursday's free Dawn barrage a
new low marking a day set aside for the
protection of children by shattering the
safety of this Man's family his
nine-year-old granddaughter was killed
along with her mother hit by Falling
debris as they raced to an air raid
shelter
Russian President Vladimir Putin
meanwhile celebrated Children's Day
virtually far from the fighting where
Ukrainian forces are keeping the Kremlin
getting about their looming
counter-offensive these troops are back
from the intense fighting on the Eastern
front line but there's no time to rest
they are care honing their Battlefield
skills
we set up grenade and training recently
mobilized recruits explains mobile drone
operator artem of the kobiansk Battalion
we were grouping there's new people
coming to us we teach them
we watch the Infantry team practice
advancing on enemy positions and
simulate clearing trenches as a two-man
unit gave covering fire from above and
drones buzzed overhead beating back
real-time intelligence to a nearby
reconnaissance team
this is a battle-hardened unit who
fought in bahmut and were part of the
lightning counter-offensive in this
region last year
there's a degree of tiredness Deputy
Commander Maxim concedes but we're
United by our Dream for Freedom a dream
that will have to sustain them as the
war enters perhaps its most crucial
phase yet
president zolenti has said that while
the U.S made Patriot air defense system
is successfully stopping most Russian
strikes until F-16 by the Jets arrive
they will continue to need more of those
Patriots Gail
yeah still thinking about your phrase a
dream for Freedom thank you very much
Deborah Potter reporting from Ukraine